the coronavirus epidemic has ravaged the world
you are too many people
it has affected the very roots of
our economy raised countless
questions about the healthcare system
in this first episode of what's left
we look at how
the  crisis has spread to the economy
I hope that we will win the sound the end of
we are a major crisis in French-speaking Switzerland in lyon
will change everything we will change everything for
me although we have not changed anything the
current crisis  offers us a unique opportunity
to think about it as the economic model of
europe and this is how
[Music]
while the countries crumble one
after the other
the economic figures are
reaching us they are not reassuring
the general freezing of the economy
a  first in modern history
causes the euro zone
to contract by 75% for this year it's the worst
recession since the great depression
until we have a relay of a vaccine
this sword of damocles hangs on the  top of
the tee  is and it generates uncertainty
in margins which are margins
we have never seen so the question of
what will happen after
the confinement in europe the jobs of
nearly 59 million people are
threatened either the  equivalent of almost the
entire population of france
behind the figures it is the way of
life of the citizens their income their
plans for the future which were called into
question overnight it took
a month of confinement before
european union leaders
decide to take action as a
united bloc
in april they agreed on
a number of measures to the tune
of 540 billion euros intended to
protect workers
companies and states  yes it's the
crisis and Europeans we draw Gaullist
attracted as went to fight
they are strong quindi of the toilets the
guests play there on the longest term
all the countries of the European union
will need cash to f  face
the economic consequences of the crisis,
that is to say to finance a
massive recovery plan
[Music]
but history can help us
understand how to approach the continuation to
jump his country the depression of the 30s
roosevelt took  radical measures
in a few years he tripled the
federal budget creates new resources
introduce a federal tax on
profits and on the richest
the first year it did not work
for a few years
roosevelt then issued bonds
with massive measures of
fiscal stimulus his plan ended up
bearing fruit
in the eyes of today's progressives
this historic precedent sketch
new exit the debt is one of the
tools available to governments to
finance their actions in normal times
all european countries can
issue bonds to
borrow money on the financial markets at some
point these countries will have to repay
the loan  nt
if the financial markets
trust your country they will
easily lend it money at low
interest rates
the first question was to say
there are countries that will be more
affected than others by this health crisis
so  I mean that the countries which are going to
have more public debt
than others but the countries which seem
less stable will see their
interest rates increase so the
financial markets can we ask you
and the effects on the capacity of a country
to  restore its economic strength are
immense what may seem an
insignificant increase in the interest rate can
quickly translate into billions of
additional euros to be repaid is that
when we only anticipate that one country wants
more affected because another we can
arbitrate its public debt against that
of a country which would be less affected
if these arbitration mechanisms occur,
we have an effect on this infernal circle which
leads to penalizing the most
affected countries
and that is  t a mechanism that is totally
unfair we have solidarity reverse
anti-solidarity the progressives in
the european parliament want to avoid this
competition between states and guarantee a
recovery based on solidarity
to this end they have proposed to
issue corona bonds at european level
in  in other words it is a question of creating
a common european debt each country
would keep its capacity but europe
intends l ol currently the
financial markets will take it as the
signature of the best of them
discover at the level there but not
only and  health I also know
to finance the recovery plan
[Music]
if the borrows money on the
financial markets as a union it
must also be able to repay as a
union consequently the
progressives advocate the creation of
new own resources  independent revenue
intended to supply the
budget of the european union
a tax on non-recyclable plastics
from res  sources drawn from
the European emissions trading system
a tax on the income of
large multinationals a tax
on digital services
a tax on financial transactions
it will ensure that
revenues from the fight against avoidance
and evasion  go where they
are needed
[Music]
after a few weeks of confinement
we woke up in a world
where the air was cleaner where
traffic was no longer a
nuisance we saw spectacular drops
in co2 emissions
however this  does not correspond to the
general situation indeed
co2 emissions
increased more rapidly last year than
during the 1960s and 1970s,
rising from 0.8 units per year to
2.8 units temperatures remain
rising everywhere and we must
never get out of this situation we have
just experienced the horror but at least
there was water coming
imagine if we do nothing  I the climate
you imagine the horror are at plougar
ea mobile and so did we understand
na na fragile the beauty of life and the
fragility of life and form finance
validate life so what is the
solution
how to protect  people's jobs and way
of life while addressing what
is probably the greatest challenge in
human history
for the socialist and democrat the
solution is called the green new deal
the green new deal it's based on  a
just transition designed to leave
no one on the sidelines as part
of a sustainable reconstruction of our
economies and our societies
I don't want a very ambitious budget
a goal of recovery and
transformation we can create 5
million jobs  sure to win the
climate battle we must isolate we must develop
public transport we must
change the agricultural model we need 300 and
500 billion progressive ideas
have finally caught the attention of the
european commission  ean finally but this
one proposed a general recovery plan
750 billion euros in support of the
economies of the block these investments will be
added to the vast existing budgetary plan
of 11,100 billion euros
it is a question of launching a
lifeline to the  hardest hit sectors in
the hardest hit regions to
allow them not to lay off
workers or shut down before
activity resumes the snd group will
continue to press
eu leaders for europe to
show up  the height of its ambitions
it is a fine success of these the problem
in bone as if the problem is serious
or not signed before joining diaries
any case which is born by European painting
is still gaston has
work at risk if a loan  for they
come from the fia winning at aulas the losers
like bmc has the charm heroes del
piero
it's the second bone at the spre also
hide generational in europe and
the corona virus crisis has us all  shocked
the first and foremost emergency was
to protect people's health
society's most vulnerable memory is to get
workers back to their jobs when
the epidemic ends
[Music] the
way we have  discovered a
world of new
possibilities working from home we
have experienced new forms of
solidarity
so when the
applause stops and normal life
gradually resumes
what will we do will we go back to our
old ways will we opt for a
real change
during this crisis the progressive au
take real change and
fought for
it we refused to be passive witnesses
to history as
workers businesses and the
planet was doomed
today the  time for boldness has
come time to build a
better future for all
[Music]